good afternoon i'm muang a postdoc
associate in plant breeding and genetics
at coronado university
working with dr michael
the title of my presentation is
illustrating the gene regulatory
landscape of natural variation for leave
culicular conductance in mace
the cuticle is a hydrophobic layer of
cutie and waxes since it says five plant
epidermal cells
plant cuticle consists of a matrix of
quilting with cuticular wax embedded
within or deposit onto its surface
cuticular conductance or gc is the rate
of water evaporation from the leaf
cuticle which accounts for
almost all the non-stomata water loss
to investigate permeability of lip
cuticle along its developmental stages
our collaborators performed a stunning
experiment and a dehydration experiment
using developing maze leaves
they showed that the last material
section or the bottom section of the
leaf were more permeable to tbo a water
soluble dye
and had a higher rate of water loss
indicating that matured leaf cuticles
could reduce plant non-stomatal water
loss comparing to immature cuticles
many studies for maize leaf cuticles
were performed on these juvenile leaves
which have more epiculticular vaccines
and have very different wax composition
from adult leaves
in this study we focused on curricular
conductance for maze adult leaf because
they are more related with plant
reproduction stages
our primary goal is to identify
candidate genes that regulate leaf gcs
through integrating genomic and
transcriptomic data
the second goal is to validate the
association between gc and our strongest
candidate gene
using mace nested near isagenix lines or
nils
curricular conductance and transcript
abundance were provided for a subset of
310 inbred lines in the wisconsin
diversity panel the entire panel with
b73 as checks were planted in two
environments in university of california
san diego
2018
gcu was evaluated for the mature primary
ear leave at the silking
the harvested leaves were kept in dark
before and through out phenotyping to
make sure stomata were closed leaves
were weighed every 45 minutes for 5
times and the gc was calculated as leaf
weight
loss
per hour adjusted by leaf surface area
for three primary sequencing analysis we
dissected the bottom ten to thirty
percent of the total leaflets for
developing adult leaf as it porked out
of the hole
due to the destructive rna sequencing
sampling methods gc phenotyping was
performed on different plants from the
same plot
to analyze the data i calculated fast
linear advice predictors or blobs for gc
to combine phenotype from two
environments
to get high density snap markers for
jivas
the genotypes had over 14 million snip
loci were imputed based on high quality
gps snips in the wisconsin diversity
panel using beagle
after filtering for imputation accuracy
minor allele frequency and in-breath
coefficient
about nine million snake markers were
retained and used for jivas
transcript abundance from two
environments were combined by
calculating blobs for each gene model
the proper
let's take estimates of expression
residuals or peer
were applied
to blobs to account for inferred
confounders that influence expression
variation
peer residuals of blobs were used for
tivas
to increase the statistical power of our
association analysis
p values of g was and t1 were integrated
in the fascist combined test
here is a summary of gwas and tiwa's
result
briefly we identified 17 plus spoken
candy genes involved in the cuticle
biofences
cell wall modification intracellular
trafficking and the regulation of
cuticle development as indicated by
these colored dots
fischer's combined tests integrated
jivas and tiwa's results and identified
additional five possible candidate genes
as highlighted by red arrows indicating
that fischer's compound test could
increase statistical power in canada
gene and identification
among these kennedy genes
istl1
was the only plausible candidate
identified by all three methods
therefore it was considered as the
strongest causal gene for gc
here is original manhattan plot that
combined the jivas and tivas result for
the one megabase region surrounding istl
one
one equal lines represent minus log two
key values for g was and dots for tivas
we see that
istl1 whose position is indicated by a
vertical dashed line is tightly linked
to a jiva's peak and its table signal is
moderately strong as indicated by red
diamond
this gene encodes an increased salt
tolerance one like one protein involved
in the formation of modern vascular
bodies
the multiverse circular body is a late
endosomal compartment
where plasma memory derived proteins are
degraded after internalization where
endocytosis
in rhabdosis isdl1 and another protein
work together to control the plasma
membrane localization of protein
including abc g9 a transporter of
driving components in the tape term of
airdropdoxes
moreover
others of is tl1 mutant
represent reduction in the accumulation
of wax component in the alkene and
sterile groups
thus it can be speculated that istl1
ortholog may facilitate the localization
of plasma memory transporter required to
export cuticle component
in mace epidermal cells and regulate
leaf cuticular
conductance
to further investigate the involvement
of istr1 in gc
we selected a set of 12 maze and nils
that cover the istl1 region from eight
donor parents with b73 background
these nails donald parents and b73 as
chaps were planted in two environments
at ucsd in 2020 for gc evaluation
best linear unbiased estimators or blues
for gc
were calculated to allow for the
comparison of gc between b73 and news
plus their donor parents
in addition
a haplotype based analysis
was performed in both the diversity
panel and news in order to validate the
association between gc and istl1 genomic
region
this is a scatter plot showing blues 4
b73 and nails and their donor parents
dot types represent the genetic sources
of istl while introgression
we compared gc between e73 and the other
experimental lines
and the p-values were adjusted using the
donuts method
four of the donor parents ki-11 and c315
oh43 and tx
303 showed significantly higher gc than
b73
most importantly compared to b73
two news with tji8 introgressions and
one male with oh 43 introgression should
significantly reduce the gc as
highlighted in red boxes
to take one step further we also want to
know if the association between gc and
the ist-01 genomic region can be
validated among nails
to do such comparison we first
constructed haplotype blocks and
performed habla-type-based association
analysis in the wisconsin diversity
panel
and this regional manhattan plot shows
results for haplotype-based association
analysis in the wisconsin diversity
panel
each of the horizontal line represent a
haplotype block
and the length of the line corresponds
to size of a block
blue means a haplotype block is
polymorphic among unused and red
represents a monomorphic block among
unused
the green narrow
region
represents the physical position of
istl1
we focused on a minus plus 200 kb window
from istl 1
as highlighted in yellow background
which is the same window we use for
candidate gene selection for gbos
in this window we selected the top 10
most associated blocks as highlighted by
a red box to test their association with
gc among unused
unfortunately
haplotype block 95
the most associated block in the
diversity panel was not polymorphic
among the nails which reduced the
statistical power and partially
explained why we didn't see much
significant difference in gc between b73
and n news due to the introgressions
of the 10 mostly associated hepatite
blocks
three hepatic blocks were significantly
associated with gc among unknowns
as these three blocks i linked this
equilibrium and showed similar effects
on gc
i will only focus on block 82 in next
slide
in the wisconsin diversity panel we
estimated haplotype effect for 10
haplotypes in block 82
among them haplotypes 1 5 and 7 were
found among anneals
comparing haplotype effects for haploid
types 1 5 and 7 from the diversity panel
and anneals
we observed strong correlation
with correlation coefficient of
0.92
although the association were estimated
from three hepatites
it indicated that
the association between gc and istl1
genomic region detected in the wisconsin
diversity panel could be validated in an
independent population
in conclusion
jiva's tivos and fischer's combined
tests identified candidate genes
involved in cuticle paraphrases cell
wall modification intracellular
trafficking and regulation of cuticle
development of lipcuticular conductance
among all these possible candidate genes
istl1 is the strongest
candidate causality that regulates mains
leave curricular conductance
tji8 introgression for the istl1 region
can significantly reduce maize leaf
cuticular conductance
and the genetic effect of istl-1 region
identified in the wisconsin diversity
panel
was verified in a hepatite based
association analysis using a news
with that i would like to thank mike and
the golab members for their support in
this project
i would like to thank
ru student equity and undergraduate
student from ucsd for helping with gc
phenotyping and the three prime ritc
collection
i would like to thank another iu student
elise for genotyping work
and dr borgworth from algema university
to perf for performing wax analysis
i would like to thank nsf for providing
the funding for this project
thank you all for listening and i'm glad
to take any questions